aurélien qui on vient de nous rejoindre
sur ce plateau bonjour vous êtes conquis
et ça se voit au vu de votre uniforme et
vous êtes secrétaire départemental du
syndicat sud
au pas de calais je suppose que vous
étiez présent tout à l'heure à la
manifestation
ouidah sont présents depuis le début de
la manifestation jusqu'à la place nation
quel est l'état d'esprit des pompiers de
vos confrères
quand on voit certaines images assez
fort en voit certains de vos confrères
tenter d'enfoncer des 0 pour passer de
l'autre côté sur le périphérique
pourquoi vouloir aller sur le boulevard
périphérique qui vous leur passé ces
barrières anti-émeutes
c'est difficile à dire je suis pas dans
leur tête mais ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est quand même pas mal de pompiers qui
sont un peu à bout après quand même
plusieurs mois de grève et à ce que ça
fait de vouloir veiller rien juste des
terriens justifiée parce que encore une
fois on a eu une manifestation le 14 le
15 octobre dernier s'est passé
exactement de la même manière aux places
nation on a été menacé et on ne pouvait
pas rejoindre nos bus où on s'est fait
gazer cherche pas d'excusé ou quoi que
ce soit il y en a qui sont plus énervés
que d'autres certainement toujours est
il que depuis quand même le mois de juin
l'année dernière on sait emmener en
grève et que les réponses à cette grève
du de la part du gouvernement
on parle de non violence physique sauf
qu'il ya de la violence psychologique
fait par le gouvernement depuis que
plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années
sur les pompiers
justement il ya une réunion cet
après-midi au ministère de l'intérieur
avec les syndicats pour discuter de
divers sujets et discuter évidemment de
vos revendications
qu'est ce que vous attendez et qu'est ce
qui peut se passer après ces valeurs et
vous des points le résultat de cette
réunion je n'ai pas été destinataire de
ce qui s'est dit à cette réunion chez
nous au niveau de notre syndicat me
soumises devait nous recevoir
sauf qu'apparemment il a tout à fait
rond qui ne soit pas utilisé ce droit
je dépense qui a été dit si on a des
avancées sur nos revendications le
mouvement s'arrêtera et tout le monde
repartira bon enfant je veux dire nous
on n'est pas content d'être là je veux
dire moi je préfère être dans ma caserne
dans ma maison avec ma famille plutôt
que de venir manifester ainsi tout
allait bien la préfecture de police de
paris a dit que certains manifestants
pénètrent dans des immeubles privés
cours de vincennes afin de contourner
dispositif pour atteindre le périodique
est ce que vous confirmez vous cette
information
moi non c'est souvent fait qu'on rentre
dans des immeubles privés parce que pour
parce qu'on est bon enfant parce qu'on
va dire bonjour aux gens parce que on
veut prendre des photos vu de dos ou
donc on va sur les étages un ou deux ou
trois quatre cinq six maintenant c'est
leur vision des choses si les considère
que les pompiers dès qu'ils sortent d'un
cortège c'est pour faire du mal ou
hausse est de contourner un système
c'est leur force est leur seul horizon
des choses c'est pas la même quel
rapport à ce que vous entretenez avec la
police y est justement le porte parole
voilà c'est ça qui est compliqué pour
nous et c'est pour ça que beaucoup
sapeurs-pompiers du 15 octobre qui ont
été blessés ils ont pas compris après
l'énervement fait beaucoup de choses
c'est à dire que sous l'énervement on
peut avoir des gestes et des paroles
provocantes qui sont venus un peu la
chose mais je veux dire moi dans le pas
de calais je je je travaille
régulièrement avec les crs et gendarmes
mobiles
les relations sont très bonnes
c'est ça quand on est menacé quand on
est encerclé on se dit [ __ ] merde
parmi les mécontents 11e pourquoi
pourquoi on vient on veut manifester
faire juste un trajet du point a au
point b
voilà on n'est pas au fait de toutes les
dispositifs qui sont mis en place qui
sont peut-être dans la norme pour eux je
suis en fait il n'est pas peut-être à
lui que la communication moi je suis un
professionnel
en fait s'ils veulent aller sur une
barricade c'est parce qu'elle est
symbolique c'est le barricades
quant au gouvernement mais une barricade
pour l'époque et qui sont issus de la
société civile est une barricade
symbolique tôt que moi je vous engage à
surtout ne pas mettre leur vie en péril
ce genre de symbole j'aurais bien voulu
que mon ministre de tutelle qui le même
que le leur prennent cinq minutes pour
recevoir ces gens issus de la société
civile pour que mini de lin de l'ariège
nov castaner eu bien sûr bien sûr
j'aimerais bien que mon ministre
prennent cinq minutes pour recevoir ces
gens est juste faire en sorte qu'ils
soient écoutés entendus et qu'il essaye
de faire en sorte que ces gens puissent
réintégrer leurs casernes et qu'on
puisse continuer comme c'était le avant
travailler tous les tous main dans la
main oui je faisais quelque chose en
tête le ministre a reçu une délégation
sur nous notre syndicat n'a pas été
reçue on est en passe et après on passe
et après il a reçu de l'intersyndicale
comme c'est déjà une bonne chose mais
toujours est il qu'on sait je ne sais
pas ce qu'il en est ressorti
en tout état de cause nous le karité
syndicats on le redit les doléances des
pompiers avec qui nous travaillons tous
les jours au quotidien parce que le
travail la police et les pompiers c'est
difficile elle pour nous nous sommes
nous semble quand même légitime
tout à fait et vous avez vous avez
complètement raison avec la barricade
oui c'est un symbole sa symbole plus il
ya de la provocation de part et d'autre
on s'amuse un peu parfois il ya des
gestes pour ça sourit parce que parfois
je vois déjà se fait par des pompiers je
dire le pompier tout seul qui pousse une
barricade c'est pas de la provocation
c'est de l'amusement c'est parce que
voilà c'est pas comme ici que j'étais
des pavés c'est pas c'est pas la même
violence qu'on peut rencontrer sur
certaines aux autres manifestations
il n'y a pas eu je pense pour l'instant
aux deux crs ou gendarmes blessés il est
bientôt à 17 heures le cortège a débuté
en début d'après midi
on est arrivé au point final de ce
défilé qui avait lieu entre la place de
la république et la place de la nation
donc un baril à quoi est-ce que vous
vous attendez ce soir jusqu'à quelle
heure entre guillemets ce siège mais je
peux utiliser ce mot peut durer son goût
alors le cg va pas durer
[ __ ] mais terrain jeudi en nous on
doit tous repartir dans nos départements
c'est pas le but de rester là-bas de
faire un siège toute la nuit alors que
j'ai été un peu pessimiste mais je
m'entends pas grand chose de la part du
gouvernement que des annonces qui vont
être faites et c'est ça en fait qui
m'attriste c'est que c'est la deuxième
manifestation nationale qu'on fait en
l'espace de quelques mois ça fait quand
même plus de sept mois aux huit mois
qu'on est en grève
justement on parle de cette grève contre
la réforme des retraites demain il ya
une nouvelle journée de
lisa sion nationale à l'appel d'une
intersyndicale de l'intersyndicale vous
en tant que pompier au lendemain de
cette manifestation des pompiers est ce
que vous y serez
parce que pour ce camp en intervention
alors moi demain des jeux cette garde
parce que j'étais bien dire que je serai
bien demain par contre oui on participe
aux manifestations contre la réforme de
la retraite non
nos tournées forme de sapeurs pompiers
parce qu'on est aussi impactée et
intervenant sur toute la société
française on se rend compte également de
certains dirigeants comptent beaucoup de
français et l'impact pour fait de cette
réforme qui est jugée pas qu'elle est
mauvaise mais elle est complètement flou
on sait pas où on va
nous on sait pas quelle sauce on va être
mangé aurélien acquérant vous êtes donc
pompiers dans le pas-de-calais
il ya des pompiers qui viennent de toute
la france dans le dijon d'autres de
bordeaux a priori sont de gros
contingents objectifs qui sont montés
deux côtés de paris les pompiers de
paris entre unitaire ne manifestent pas
mais est-ce que
au contact avec eux et des spectacles
les mêmes chances à autant démanteler
par n'y pense pas les pompiers de paris
sont soumis à un régime que le régime
militaire est repris de paris sont pas
la france et ils ont une hiérarchie qui
est très stricte
ils sont pas utiles ici d'insultés
sélection des professionnels donc c'est
pas eux qui vont manifester s'ils
manifestent
là ça serait quand même dommage pour eux
ça par contre c'est tout à fait vrai
c'est les militaires dont un militaire
peut pas manifester parce que c'était
justement d'où la question à l'entente
militaire ils ne manifestent pas mais
quelques il pense ne sont pas mûrs avec
eux je pense qu'il y en a qui sont
militaires qui y voit que la vision de
militaires qui comprennent pas parce que
surtout quand on voit certains certains
gestes effectués par mes collègues pour
eux c'est peut-être parfois un peu la
tenue mais il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
pompiers de paris sont également compter
dans nos rangs dans l'union civile grâce
au volontariat et une fois qu'ils ont
fini leur quelques années à paris
ils reviennent chez nous donc les
manifestations qu'on fait maintenant
le pompier de paris qui va arriver dans
le civil après elle va en bénéficier de
toutes les mrc pourra avoir donc je
pense que moralement ils sont avec nous
même si aurélien qui en est à l'heure
très peu inquiété sur ce qu'apportera la
colère disait normalement c
ces barricades elles pourront pas céder
finalement elles ont cédé avec également
la préfecture de police de paris
un post sur twitter qui datent de 9 90
des manifestants ce bloc périphérie au
niveau des portes de vincennes et de
saint mandé l'intervention et forme de
l'enva permis de relancer la sûreté
nationale dans les deux sens donc ya eu
une incursion sur le boulevard
périphérique alors que là on est en
train d'y suivre
un manifestant a priori qui est blessé
c'est véritablement en train de
s'envenimer
comment ça va se terminer comme toutes
les autres manifestations de
sapeurs-pompiers à chaque manifestation
sapeurs-pompiers il ya a loupé risque
qui est bloquée un moment donné à chaque
manifestation de pompiers il ya ça se
termine sur la place de la nation
il disait tout à l'heure le c'est
symbolique cette sauvegarde
le fait de l'avoir ouverte
les pompiers sont 100% content
maintenant espérons que le gouvernement
va céder de la même manière mais je vais
pas cautionner ses partants que je
crains un an j'ai beaucoup de collègues
qui sont à bout
ils ont vraiment marre de je peux pas
cautionner mais je comprends que ça veut
dire que la l'exaspération justifier la
violence ça dépend ce que vous attendez
compte violence
là on parle de violence physique moi
j'ai parlé je leur ai dit ok alors le
voit des images de pompiers pris en
charge par des médecins dreux des strips
nédic un policier a priori touché à une
jambe un autre à une main et on a
entendu tout à l'heure au micro de guy
marosi l'un de vos confrères évoqué le
chiffre de 1 blessé a priori en aura
plus
c'est possible c'est toujours à la fin
où on fait le compte de toute façon donc
ça reste des blessés légers
j'ai tant que ça reste des blessés
légers malheureusement c'est pas plus
graves
donc ça en reste là
maintenant à chaque manifestation de
sapeurs-pompiers qu'on a connus ces
dernières années ça s'est terminé ça
s'est passé exactement de la même
manière
c'est juste que ces deux dernières il ya
de l'exaspération dans nos rangs il ya
peut-être un petit peu plus de violence
psychologique mise par le ministère et
gouvernements qui se succèdent
on est face à des gouvernements se
succèdent qui sont hypocrites et depuis
des années des années envers les sapeurs
tenter de nous remettre des beaux
discours et des médailles a plus grand
chose de costaud pour nous jean-pierre
colombien c'est bien de nous rejoindre
bonjour vous êtes le porte parole de
l'association union des policiers
nationaux indépendants vous êtes ancien
commandant de police
quand on voit ces images
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'elle vous
évoque de prime abord on voit de façon
dramatique l'opposition entre des
services où travaille quotidiennement
ensemble
il servit de sécurité qui s'engagent et
qui s'était pas des risques physiques et
d'ici là comment ils arrivent
aujourd'hui à voir toutes les strates
que la fonction publique etc obligé de
descendre dans la rue et de la nuit
festive nous y avoir vraiment étudié
insupportable maintenant se poser les
bonnes questions est de savoir ce qu'on
attend pour poser sur la table est vrai
problème les vrais sujets surtout est ce
qu'il ya la vraie volonté politique ne
s'y attaquer mais ce que accord on
assiste là moi me désespère quand on
voit les pompiers quand on sait le
boulot qu'ils font au quotidien de voir
que ils sont en plein affrontement avec
les forces de police jeu quelques
spectacles d'avant et déprimant au
revoir en direct sur ces images une
personne au sol prise en charge un
attroupement autour d'une personne a
priori donc baisser espérant évidemment
que ce ne soit pas trop grave
on a aperçu évidemment des jets de canon
à eau un aperçu des lacrymogènes
d'ailleurs quels types de grenades sont
utilisés aujourd'hui qu'il est petit ce
positif de sécurité définies sienne des
lacrymogènes grenades de désencerclement
klyuev 4 on en a entendu de la part de
christophe castaner dimanche dernier le
retrait de ces grenades qui ont blessé
un des manifestants notamment depuis le
17 novembre 2018 date
la première manifestation des jets les
jaunes d'oeufs
d'armes entre guillemets sont utilisés
aujourd'hui quand les manifestants si je
vous ferai une réponse des victoires
retentissantes moqueries que soit le
type de dilution qui sont employés c'est
la philosophie d'emploi qui compte c'est
ce qu'on sait ce qu'on veut faire et à
corps utilise des forces de maintien de
l'ordre
une personne semble-t-il on joue pas on
voit des images sont directs sont les
commente une personne
on constate d aider des gouttes
ophtalmologiques dans saisie a priori
donc il ya des lacrymo est ce que ça
peut être également des éclats de sa
possible de le dire c'est que j'espère
que ce n'est que dix lacrymogènes enfin
quelle que soit la munition on utilise
si elles vous touchent au visage elle
peut occasionner des dégâts
irrémédiables professionnels de db sur
douala de désastre de désencerclement
pardon si elle est projetée au niveau
supérieur du corps elle peut occasionner
des blessures vraiment très profonde
enfin la voûte vraiment se poser de
bonnes questions je suis désolé de le
dire mais on a toutes les strates de la
fonction publique manifeste que sur
l'éducation nationale la santé il se
rappelle la police
je suis pas là en tant que représentant
de l'institution policière je suis là en
tant que représentant parfois et bien
signé la parole au nom de policiers qui
ont eux aussi ras-le-bol de la façon
dont ils sont recommandés malade j'ai
utilisées et aujourd'hui je peux vous
assurer qu'il n'est pas une majorité de
fonctionnaires de police ravi de servir
je dirais dans l'histoire sociale dans
le cadre des négociations qui sont en
cours comme la part de mouvements
d'église certaines 40 gens qu'il ya une
grève il ya des mouvements c'est fou ce
type
un an et demi que ça dure un an et demi
que vous santa fe du moment des gigolos
aux mouvements divers et variés
syndicalistes et autres à quel moment on
va vraiment posé le problème et ce
gouvernement va-t-il entendre ceux qui
ont des choses à dire et des
propositions à faire
éjaculats dans les syndicats de police
tout simplement
comment est-ce que vous interprétez vous
ces images aurélien et qui arrange
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
départemental du syndicat sud du pas de
calais vous est donc venu du nord de la
france pour participer à cette
manifestation
ces images voir certains de vos
collègues qui sont administrés des
gouttes dans les yeux à voir certains
autres qui a priori sont baissés en
impliquant on l'a vu des blessures aux
mains ou aux jambes
qu'est ce que ça vous évoque avec des
collègues à bout qui essaie d'enfoncer
des barrières symbole ief c'est en fait
ça m'évoque au niveau des blessures
voire déboucher dans les yeux c'est ce
qui guide les crimes aux jeunes je veux
dire j'ai fait vraiment pas ce souci là
dessus c'est habituel on commence on est
là là là là là c'est je veux dire c'est
un violent oui oui pour avoir vécu
d'autres manifestations dans le cadre
des secours j'ai déjà vu des blessés
bien plus grave toujours est-il que
comme le disait monsieur à côté
et peu importe la munition qui utilisent
et si elle l'utilisé c'est qu'à un
moment donné ils ont reçu l'ordre et
c'est plus ça en fait qui m'attriste
c'est que dans une fois à chaque fois
qu'on vient c'est la seule réponse tombe
bien moi j'en veux pas du tout à des
collègues gendarmes ou policiers parce
que en fait ils reçoivent juste l'ordre
de spécial
et voilà bon après il ya des mentalités
qui s'échauffe de part et d'autre qui
peuvent arriver à des gestes qui sont
plus ou moins violents de part et
d'autre
voilà c'est attristant mais moi ce qui
m'attriste c'est la ccl l'action et la
réponse plutôt la non réponse du
gouvernement
je vous disais tout à leur guise et qui
sont hypocrites depuis des années on a
un gouvernement qui est parfois européen
quand ça l'arrangé a parfois français
quand ça les arrange nous on a des
textes européens et qui nous donne
raison à sauf que comme ça va leur
coûter des sous il préférait de français
et faire les lois à la française par
contre si la loi européenne donnait
raison aux gouvernements pour payer
moins cher il serait vite on est un quoi
donc en fait si sa prison ils sont
hypocrites sur la manière dont il gère
depuis des années
je veux le faire discuter des années je
rappelle que la prime de zone n'a plus
été revalorisé depuis 1990 donc avec
plusieurs gouvernements avant cela
évidemment leur gouvernement hollandais
länder donnent à l'époque du
gouvernement chirac
c'est pas qu'on demande et 25% pour dire
de sa revente parce que à l'époque la
prime de risque de policiers était de 25
ans maintenant vous demandez vous
jugeront si 100 du salaire de base quand
3 19% un accès sans pour être à chaque
fois qu'on a des discours on est sur les
forces de sécurité publique on y lit à
pompiers la police et la gendarmerie et
au final on voit que les policiers on a
tous été pompier sur l'a19 en toi mon
métier est moins dense je ne dis pas
qu'on a les mêmes missions
mais c'est parfois on nage pas ce temps
de laisser malheureusement tant de morts
dans nos rangs et dans les rangs de la
police
on voit évidemment ce qui se passe dans
la rue en aperçoit également sur les
côtés on le voit pas forcément on pense
forcément on aperçoit également des
vitrines qui sont baissées il ya des
commerçants on peut y avoir des
restaurants qu'est-ce que
vous dites à ces personnes qui au final
n'ont rien demandé à personne et qui
sont les victimes collatérales fast a
demandé aux préfectures de choisir notre
trajet voilà c'est pas moi qui ai choisi
trajet quoi il admire ça mais j'ai
écouté plusieurs confédérations
tout à leur taille et des choses qui
sont carrément du silence je l'entendais
dire que il avait quasiment fallu
attendre d'être un point de non retour
pour obtenir une note du ministre de
l'intérieur est d'avoir une équipe d'une
certaine manière dans quels cas
république vuitton où il faut aller
seront justement à ce casting on peut
dîner mais pour avoir une écoute un
dialogue et des propositions entre eux
c'est ça que je comprends pas on a dit
que justement dans une question de
blocage en tout cas en pâtit des années
et on en arrive à un moment donné on bat
pour se faire entendre il faut aller
dans la rue sont pliés fort est
effectivement passée à des harkis passer
à la vitesse supérieure d'une certaine
manière et ce qui est insupportable
d'entendre c'est que justement il faut
attendre d'en arriver là pour que il ya
un semblant d coûte parce que j'ai pu
comprendre encore c'était pas seulement
des propositions fermes mais des
engagements
fait loi à la va vite mais ce n'est pas
véritablement officialisé par ce pas
sécurisé c'est donc à partir de là c'est
encore une fois de plus la porte ouverte
à des mobilisations antérieures mais ça
concerne les papiers comme je le
rappelle ça concerne aussi la police qui
fait partie de la grande maison de la
fonction publique qui est donc
exactement à la même enseigne que c'est
que ses petits camarades de l'éducation
nationale ou de la santé et que ce qui
se joue aujourd'hui au delà de ce qui ce
qui est en jeu pour les pompiers c'est
ce système social qui est que nous avons
en france et ce qu'on veut encore dans
ce pays une fonction publique un service
public qu'on l'a connue apparemment on
de glisser vers une sorte de système à
l'anglo-saxonne opéra qui voudra à qui
voudra bien
beaucoup sont ne sont pas de cet avis et
apparemment c'est ce qui est exprimé
actuellement dans les rues mais c'est là
où il ya un problème c'est qu'on n'est
pas du tout sûre même logiciel ou
gouvernement et on est sur une dynamique
néolibérale avec un engagement sur le
déclassement des missions de service
public vers des officines privées et là
ça pose un vrai problème du mois
s'appelle un problème de société et un
dialogue de société qui n'est pas qui
n'est réglé que par une opposition
frontale entre services services divers
services institutionnels et les services
de police comme si la police était
finalement le les flancs de négociation
indispensable avant d'arriver aux portes
des ministères
ce n'est pas entendable de mon point de
vue et y compris pour la police qui suit
donc dans l'image se déprécie à une
vitesse qu'on n'a jamais vus
parce qu'effectivement elle apparaît
comme l'interlocuteur idoine de tous les
ministères et ses partants table vous
parler d'eux
image de la police qui est en train de
chuter quand il ya des scènes comme sa
violente de la part des pompiers qui
sont d'habitude apprécié de la part de
la population française puisque ce sont
les pompiers qui viennent porter les
premiers secours
est ce que ça peut porter atteinte à
l'image des pompiers vis-à-vis de
l'opinion publique française
c'est possible oui c'est possible et
c'est compréhensible veut dire les
personnes et ils vont les
sapeurs-pompiers des gens qui viennent
sauver pas des gens qui agressent la
police donc oui en effet je peux
comprendre que ça peut que choquer et en
faire pâtir un peu notre notoriété
auprès de la population
mais ça reste anodin par rapport à su ce
que ce qu'on subit depuis des années je
veux dire on est on est pas là on
collecte par les à côtés des autres
services
il ya également dans le cortège des je
pensais aux infirmiers et les hôpitaux
nous on travaille tous les jours aussi
également avec les insurgés hôpitaux les
urgences et on voit ce dépérir le
service médical actuel vous parlez à des
hospitaliers présent au sein du cortège
aujourd'hui on a aperçu également deux
figures emblématiques des gilet jaune
présent au sein du cortège jérôme
relégué en cfa within lellouche le fait
qu'il soit présent à vos côtés comment
ce que vous l'analysez et comment est ce
que vous le percevez alors moi
personnellement je peux dire que je m'en
fous parce que tout soutien est bon à
prendre
je ne vois pas où est le soucis l'an
manifeste pour une retraite je pense que
le mouvement des jeunes manifestent
aussi pour ça j'ai pas dire qui doit
être présent ou pas présent dans le
cortège
comme on appelle à manifester les
pompiers s'il y en a qui se connaissent
qui veulent nous soutenir par tout
moment où ils le font dans des mesures
légale et cohérente avec eux mêmes
il n'y a aucun souci quoi je veux dire
tant qu'il ya pas de récupération
politique pour quoi que ce soit comme en
attaque on entend parfois
j'en tire qu en baisse je fais un petit
peu embarrassé c'est un petit peu dans
la position de celui qui représente une
institution de bon gré mal gré est-ce
que des jd je n'y ai pas de gilet jaune
dans la manifestation des policiers
qu'il a eu il ya quelques mois mais je
pense qu envie de vous dire qu'ils
auraient pu y être puisque ce qu'ils
étaient exprimés soit par le gilet jaune
ou par toutes les corporations elle voit
ici à l'image un jérôme rodriguez
justement en train de saluer des
notre d'autres manifestants et à ses
côtés donc un sosie lellouche le goaler
gilet jaune qui le gilet jaune qui peut
d'ailleurs se confondre avec les bandes
fluorescentes jaune présenterai sur
l'univers et des pompiers j'ai envie de
vous tout le monde en arrêtant que dans
les hauteurs de pleurs etc
non mais qui soit là et que ce soit sur
la voie publique et participe où
s'agrègent manifestation il a
parfaitement le droit il faut toujours
faire la part des choses
j'ai participé à beaucoup de tête haute
et d où ont commenté des les
manifestations du gilet jaune je crois
que donc on ce qu'on a on a utilisé pas
mal de raccourcis faciles entre ce qui
est exprimé la grande majeure partie des
manifestants et quelques blocs qui est
essayée effectivement de déstabiliser et
de donner une autre teinte à ces
manifestations que je qualifie mois de
populaire pas de gilet jaune gilet jaune
savoir rien dire c'était des gens de la
population très diverse et variée
allez y aller dans ces manifestations
j'y suis allé pour me rendre ton de
qu'ils se trouvent et qui battaient le
pavé
vous aviez tout des personnes âgées des
coupes des enfants parfois c'est pas
très recommandé ni malin ça joue la
corde mais il y avait de tout et aussi
des black blocks bien sûr mais c'était
quoi c'était un centième de la
manifestation et tout le monde s'il
focaliser tout le monde a fait ce qu
avec des jabs hoc
aujourd'hui au sein de la manifestation
parmi les personnes qui ont tenté
d'enfoncer les
les barricades on avait des personnes
masquées on avait également des
paupières ouais si si les pompiers sont
masquées pour se protéger des gaz
également des fumigènes qu'on peut avoir
sur toute la manifestation ils sont pas
masqué pour couvrir leur visage
c'est nous que boule de feu ça peut être
assimilée comme ça je comprends
après des black blocks je pense que je
n'ai pas connaissance qui ait une seule
vitrine cassée ou détérioré sur le
parcours donc c'est pour ça je vois pas
un black blocks à défaut enfoncé au quoi
que ce soit sur le parcours parce que
tout simplement c'est pas de ma critique
et je pense qu'il doit et éviter vie
tracé alors notre part c'est déjà arrivé
sur cette manifestation départementale
s'est pas alors leur mode de
fonctionnement journée les goûts
glassblock agissent de manière beaucoup
plus facile lorsque des manifestations
sont d'ampleur qu'elle réunit des
dizaines de milliers de personnes là on
aller face à un groupe de professionnels
puissent connaissent tous du moins pas
beaucoup se connaissent et connaissent
et il n'a aucun intérêt
effectivement à ce qu'il sait déborder
par des rires et des groupuscules ou
identitaires ou autre je pense que là ce
n'est pas le débat des débats il est que
et une colère et ça va bien falloir les
prendre en contre elle s'explique
aujourd'hui face à vous savez façade et
c'est assez j'espère que ni d'un côté ni
de l'autre y aura donc deux blessés
sérieux vraiment pas ce que je sais sur
cette catastrophe mais ne voyons pas les
black blocks partout voyons de colère il
ya une colère elle est institutionnel
des les profondes ne pas l'entendre
je me permets de vous remercier
aurélien 10 ans
d'être revenue sur ce plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
départemental du syndicat sud dans le
pas de calais vous devez nous quitter et
forcément vous avez un train à prendre
pour rentrer un bus à prendre pour
pouvoir renverser soudan nord de la
france merci beaucoup
j'ai toujours présents sur ce plateau
sur ce plateau
jean-pierre colombiès porte parole de
l'ue béni l'union des policiers
nationaux indépendants si un commandant
de police la nuit est en train de tomber
progressivement sur paris la soirée
selon bout elle peut prendre quelle
forme on a entendu mon âme ou dès lors
dire tantôt il ya des tensions tantôt
c'est un petit peu plus calme là a
priori on assiste à un calme précaire
je ne pense pas que ça s'éternisera
enfin c'est un avis totalement subjectif
je suis pas dans la tête des
organisateurs de la manifestation la
façon des pompiers donc on n'est pas
face à des irresponsables on est face à
des gens qui ont exprimé leur colère qui
ont exprimé leurs revendications par la
voix de leur représentant et je vois pas
comment ça pourrait mal se terminer
ce que je vois ce que j'imagine ce que
j'espère c'est que tout simplement tout
le monde retourne le plus tranquillement
du monde vers le moyen de transport et
regagnent leur région d'origine
on n'est pas face à des gens qui ont une
volonté de déstabiliser la société
on est face à des gens qui ont pour
ambition pour volonté de se faire
entendre comme beaucoup d'autres
d'ailleurs comme je le répète les
hospitaliers ou même les policiers
lorsqu'ils ont à manifester faut pas
l'oublier
donc ya pas de raison pour que ça
tourner à l'émeute ou des idées des
confrontations conre comparable avec ce
que l'on connaît avec les black blocks
le cours de vincennes les manifestants
violents je cite prenant à partie les
forces de l'ordre comment est-ce que
vous analysez ce chiffre cette
information jean pierre colombiès deux
personnes interpellées aujourd'hui une
crise et un chiffre infinitésimale
si tout dépend de ce que ces personnes
ont fait si elles ont commis des délits
c'est normal qu'elle cet été interpellé
mais enfin on est dedans on est dans des
chiffres qui sont plus anecdotiques que
révélateur ce qui est intriguant c'est
que de plus en plus les jours se suivent
et se ressemblent j'aurais pas qu'on en
est à une manifestation par jour mais
pas loin on en est et cadets samedi
maintenant ça se démultiplient et une
colère une colère de fond une colère
sociale
j'espère que le ministère de l'intérieur
fin je ne doute pas une seule seconde
que le ministère de l'intérieur
regardent les mêmes images que nous faut
espérer qu'ils en tirent sur tout les
bonnes conclusions ça par contre j'en
doute parce que c'est pas possible on
peut pas on ne peut pas accepter que le
rapport entre ceux qui gouvernent et
ceux qui peuplent un pays se limitent à
des confrontations hebdomadaire ou
quotidienne se faire quelque chose qui
dépasse un petit peu lente en demandant
ce qui se passe dans
dans ce pays est une vraie interrogation
à avoir sur le sujet je le ratage
insiste la police n'est pas
systématiquement là comme porte parole
du gouvernement
parler du ministère de l'intérieur
sachez que le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner a posté un tweet il
ya 32 minutes
mais ce n'était pas sur ce qui se passe
actuellement à paris alors qu'on voit
certains manifestants masqués pour se
protéger un des ces débats ce que
professionnel c'est pas des masques
voilà donc je disais un tweet il ya
trente deux minutes mais pour le retour
aux 90 km/heure et non à propos donc de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
évidemment on attend très certainement
une déclaration officielle de la part du
ministre de l'intérieur dans dans les
heures à venir
peut-être peut-être je sais pas s'ils en
avaient la certitude de ce genre dans sa
cave certain du tout j'en arrive parce
qu à redouter des prises de paroles ou
des commentaires hasardeux sur des
événements sociaux comme cela j'ai
entendu comme vous
commentaires du président de la
confédération des métiers sapeurs
pompiers qui en fait fait une annonce
qui est un petit peu entre deux
puisqu'il fait état de promesses écrites
mais ne m'ont encore absolument certaine
donc avec toujours la porte ouverte à
une nouvelle mobilisation dans l'avenir
je sais pas si aujourd'hui il ya une
priorité absolue à faire un commentaire
sur les 90 km heure pas certain
d'ailleurs c'était un sujet polémique
sachant qu'il n'y avait pas eu de
concertation vraiment très élargie au
niveau des territoires donc je sais pas
qu'est ce que le ministère de
l'intérieur à l'intention de faire je
serai bien que de savoir pour les quarts
le voir sur ces images de nombreuses
personnes qui sont donc venus sur paris
pour manifester plusieurs milliers de
pompiers pour dénoncer le manque
d'effectifs et de reconnaissance de leur
profession
répertorier leurs revendications une
revalorisation de la prime du feu ils
demandent 28 % du salaire de base contre
10 9% actuellement pour être à hauteur
des primes de risque accordés aux
policiers aux gendarmes les pompiers
demandent également le maintien de leurs
effectifs
la garantie du maintien de leur système
de retraite actuel c'est une meilleure
protection face aux agressions dont le
nombre augmente chaque année
qu'est ce qui se passe là en train un
pompier à une personne des forces de
l'ordre qui situe juste derrière il ya
une frontière qui est physique les on
voit comme des discussions ne vous
échappera pas que des revendications des
pompiers ressemble étrangement à celle
que les syndicats de police font depuis
des mois reconnaissance du métier
reconnaissance de la dangerosité des
forces républicaines les forces
régaliennes exactement on en revient au
même au même débat entourant c'est le
débat le débat sur la défense du service
public et la qualité du service public
quand les pompiers réclament avoir des
effectifs la hauteur avec la police
réclament la même chose c'est pas
simplement par confort d'ailleurs c'est
pas un gros mot non plus de travailler
dans le confort elle demande simplement
d'être en capacité d'exercer les
missions que l'état leur a assigné dans
le cas d'une philosophie républicaine
alors soit on va dans cette ligne et on
accorde effectivement s'interroge se
pose le problème de savoir si ces
services là ont les moyens d'exercer
leurs missions régaliennes
soit on considère qu'elles n'ont pas
avoué avoir ça veut dire qu'on a une
autre philosophie
en ce qui concerne la sécurité ou la
santé de ce pays c'est tout le débat est
là
est-ce que
mais les primes doivent être équivalente
ou parce qu'andy des gens dire oui mais
je suis pas délégué syndical je suis pas
dans l'intersyndicale
mais la réflexion de base me conduirait
à le faire puisque on s'est servi saab
dépendent tous de la fonction publique
la vraie question qui se pose c'est ce
qu'il ya derrière tout ça dès qu'elle
est l'arrière pensée qui est derrière
des pouvoirs que vous avez raison de
souligner c'est par un pouvoir l'aider
pouvoir qui ont laissé pourrir une
situation qui fait qu'aujourd'hui des
états des institutions tout entier n'ont
plus les moyens de fonctionner ce temps
ce service de santé dans l'éducation
jean paré moi je suis moins vous
informer sur ce secteur mais vous
entendez l'époque et réclame exactement
la même chose que les services de police
allez-vous provenir des commissariats de
france et de navarre et vous y
constaterez partout la même chose à
savoir un manque d'effectif considérable
entre 30 et 50 % parfois d'effectifs en
moins des moyens matériels qui sont à
mourir de rire favier qui sont
grotesques des bâtiments qui sont
parfois hors usage
il ya un moment donné faut savoir ce que
l'on veut quoi est-ce qu'on veut
conserver que le public est là je parle
du public je parle du citoyen je parle
de véritablement de ceux qui sont dans
l'attenté d'une réponse de l'état et
skin so véritablement est-ce qu'ils ont
véritablement l'outil de la fonction
publique ils méritent
alors j'ai une réponse à celle amiens je
dis non non pas cet outil parce
qu'actuellement les services de l'état
ont renoncé d'une certaine manière
exercer leurs missions
on revoit jean-pierre colombiès à
l'image indé
des vidéos des images de tout à l'heure
de cet après midi certaines des images
les plus impressionnantes et plus
violente si j'ose dire entre les forces
de l'ordre et les pompiers qui demandons
qu'on a compris une revalorisation
notamment de leurs primes de ce sommet
ils veulent également à la garantie du
maintien de leur système de retraite
actuel alors que demain il ya une
nouvelle journée de mobilisation à
l'appel de l'intersyndicale pour
demander le retrait du projet de loi de
la réforme des retraites
et ce alors que le premier ministre leur
philippe s'est exprimé aussi vous avez
dans l'étude d'impact un nombre
considérable d'informations
ce quatre jours donc après la
publication de milliers de pages de
cette analyse je cite encore l'ensemble
des données sur la table et c'est tant
mieux car nous n'avons pas peur des
débats voilà donc pour pour edwards
philippe concernant le projet de réforme
des retraites
je détiens pas la vérité absolue en
matière de débat des retraites
loin s'en faut mais quand j'entends dire
que la porte est ouverte pour les débats
mais oui bah y'a plus qu'à alors donc je
suspends dont toute tentative de réforme
et revenons enfin qu'il revienne plus
tôt aux jeux sont faits pour partie mais
mais qu'il revienne une véritable table
des débats remettre qui leur mettent
véritablement le projet sur la table et
non pas qu'il propose au parlement par
l'état pour une validation qu'ils auront
nécessairement parce qu'ils ont la
majorité
non mais enfin je sais pas on là je ne
comprends pas je suis papa en de lutter
jusqu'aux je comprends pas du tout
qu'est ce qu'on veut qu'est ce qu'on
veut au lieu que ça continue on veut que
la majorité des concitoyens se se
révoltent caisse ou je ne sais pas il ya
un vrai problème de dialogue ouvert au
débat c'est pas du tout conforme à ce
qu'on entend on prédisait de l'ensemble
des syndicats
en tout cas de la plupart je suis pas
non plus n était ni la cgt ni iphone ni
à vince à 1 ni ailleurs d'ailleurs on
voit des nuages de fumée de lacrymogène
avec la nuit qui est en train de tomber
ce sont des images assez confus ce que
l'on voit
des scènes n'ont pas de aussi des scènes
de guérilla urbaine puisqu'on a vu comme
des tirs de gaz lacrymogènes de canons à
eau
il faut savoir raison garder jean-pierre
colombiès vous êtes toujours présent sur
sur ce plateau je vais vous remercier le
mot de la fin
il me semble qu'il est il oui d'abord on
sait pas encore vraiment on n'est pas
encore dans une configuration de
guérilla urbaine comme on l'a été sur
des manifestations très dur il mois de
décembre notamment et justine également
des scènes de violence ouais enfin très
modéré quand même très très modéré juste
une dernière chose les paroles du
pompier que vous avez entendu je peux
vous assurez vous pourriez les entendre
dans la bouche de n'importe quel gardien
de la paix de france merci beaucoup
jean-pierre colombiès d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le porte parole de l'ue penny
l'association des unions des policiers
nationaux indépendants et vous êtes
ancien commandant de police
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à une
question directe jean pierre colombier